valentina además este acuerdo se firma
un día antes de que el gobierno de eeuu
hubiera cerrado precisamente por falta
de fondos ya firma entonces esta ley de
ayuda económica que incluye 600 dólares
de cheques para cada estadounidense que
gane menos de 75 mil dólares al año
incluye también un el revivir el paquete
de ayuda al desempleo de subsidio al
desempleado que le otorgará entonces al
desempleado 300 dólares semanales por 11
semanas irá también 284 mil millones de
dólares en una línea de crédito a
pequeñas empresas una línea de crédito
estaba cerrada también por falta de
fondos el paquete incluye ayudas también
de 15 mil millones de dólares a teatros
y a centros culturales que se han visto
afectados precisamente por las medidas
sanitarias y pues se demoró tanto
valentina porque demócratas y
republicanos pues primero estaban
enfocados en el tema electoral también
en todas las demandas de fraude que hubo
de parte del presidente trump
y obviamente por temas ideológicos
cristóbal pese a que es el segundo
paquete más grande en la historia del
país los demócratas y varios expertos
han asegurado que es insuficiente
si de hecho el paquete inicialmente iba
a ser valentina de 1,4 billones de
dólares sin embargo la negociación
termina quedando en cerca de 900 mil
millones de dólares es uno de los
paquetes más grandes de ayuda económica
pero los economistas están diciendo que
no va a ser suficiente teniendo en
cuenta la grave crisis económica y la
cantidad de negocios que han cerrado de
hecho el líder demócrata del senado
socks joner dice que este apenas es un
principio y que se pueden venir en
nuevos paquetes de ayuda económica en el
futuro de hecho joe biden el presidente
electo lo dijo también en el pasado y lo
ha repetido varias veces que cuando
llegue a la casa blanca el 20 de enero
va a tratar y avanzar un nuevo paquete
de ayuda económica que superará en este
caso el 1,5 billones de dólares